I'm James an engineer on the what if
tool I'm Sara a developer advocate on
cloud AI platform we're gonna give you
an introduction into how you can use the
what-if tool to better understand your
machine learning models we'll also show
you how to run it on various platforms
and model types so James can you tell
everyone what the what-if tool is and
when they should use it the one of tool
is a visual interface designed to help
you understand your datasets and the
output of your machine learning models
you can run it with minimal code from
many different platforms including
Jupiter notebooks collab tensor board
and cloud platform notebooks analysis
using the what-if tool can be helpful
during train data collection Moloch
creation and post-training evaluation so
you've tried the what-if tool on a bunch
of platforms what are all the ways you
can use it the would've tool supports
tensorflow models out of the box and can
support models built with any other
framework with just a few lines of code
you can also use the what-if tool with
your models deployed on cloud a guy
platform let's start with an example in
collab here we've trained a tensor flow
model on this Iowa housing data set from
Kaggle it's a binary classification
model that predicts whether a house is
worth more or less than hundred sixty
thousand dollars we can instantiate the
what if tool with a few lines of code by
passing it a set of test data points
along with the ground truth labels for
those examples the what-if tool has
three tabs with different features and
the initial view were dropped into is
the data point editor here we can see
our models prediction for each data
point we've sent to the what-if tool
blue points indicate houses our model
classified as above $160,000
in the data point editor we can also
inspect individual data points change
feature values create custom
visualizations and much more
the next tab performance and fairness
shows a couple of common evaluation
metrics for our model it also wants a
slice data by different features and
apply various strategies to optimize for
fairness the final tab features shows us
how balanced our data set is for each
feature we can see the range of values
for the data we've sent to the what-if
tool you can load the features tab with
only a data set even before you've
trained a model that's awesome do you
want to show how you can use the what-if
tool for models to put on cloud platform
yes here are a few models I've deployed
on AI platform I'll open up an AI
platform notebook instance here to
analyze this XG boost model then I
create an instance of the wit config
builder this time using the set AI
platform model method passing at my
Google Cloud project ID model name and
model version the weight config builder
contains more methods to customize the
what-if tool for your use case I noticed
two your models are trained on the same
data set can you show us how we can use
the would've tool to compare them sure
all I need to do is add a line to my wit
config builder to tell it which model I
want to compare now you can compare the
performance of both models using various
capabilities in the what if tool I
should also mention that you can use the
what-if tool for both classification
models and regression models so to recap
we've introduced you to using the
what-if tool on various platforms and
model types stay tuned for more videos
to learn what you can do in the data
point editor and performance and
fairness tabs of the tool you can also
check out more what-if tool demos in the
links below to see how it works with
image and text models thanks for
watching
[Music]